so this is a program that is motivated
and driven by a really long term vision
to understand the fundamental building
blocks of matter and how they behave
this one of these driving questions of
humanity that we want to understand how
our world works that we want to
understand where we are coming from we
have gathered a team with a team of very
international with across different
continents and I challenge you and
funding scheme which allows you to do
this like FIFA really for them it's not
a problem
on the contrary for them it's even an
accent and we saw that this is really a
very complex project that's big that the
two of us could not master ourselves and
then the most natural thing that came to
our mind is Seifer see if I can do this
see if I connect fast it can enable
collaborations also see record of
enabling collaborations very efficiently
he can do the math and also it can clue
what is what is 15 together and only one
program and hold them open and of course
this in turn data on work also has
impact on other decision as relief
techniques and methods that we developed
will later on him and this is strongly
related to questions such as what
happened during the Big Bang why is
there more matter than antimatter so why
are we here actually what is the nature
of dark matter that we observe in the
universe and how actually these
processes of these particles dis
fundamental building blocks how this
takes place
[Music]